hey this is presh talwalkar
in honor of president's day i want to
share how george washington and abraham
lincoln understood the value of
mathematics
here's a quote from george washington
without arithmetic the common affairs of
life are not to be managed with success
the study of geometry and the
mathematics with due regard to the
limits of it is equally advantageous
i previously shared a story about
abraham lincoln which i'll summarize
here
lincoln paused his law studies to learn
what it meant to demonstrate a proof
he found his answer by studying the
geometry books of euclid's elements an
ancient greek textbook
so whatever you think about the
following homework problems you should
appreciate their historical value
these manuscripts have survived hundreds
of years and they show math problems
then are remarkably similar to math
problems today
so both of these problems involve
calculating simple interest
here's a problem when george washington
was about 13 years old if 100 pounds
gains 6 pounds in 12 months
how much would 75 pounds gain in the
same time
now you should also use pounds shillings
and pence to write your answer where 20
shillings is equal to a pound and 12
pence is equal to one shilling
you should not write your answer in
fractional pounds because they used
pounds shillings and pence in his
homework
now here's a problem from abraham
lincoln at about age 16.
if 100 in one year gains three and a
half dollars interest
what some will gain
38.5
in one year and a quarter
can you figure these problems out
give them a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video for a solution
so let's first tackle george
washington's homework
he did the following calculation
essentially
he did 75
times the interest rate of 6 per 100
pounds
so 75 times 6 is equal to 450 and this
should be divided by a hundred
now 100 goes into 450 four times evenly
and then we have a sort of remainder of
50 over 100
so how do we deal with this fractional
amount of a pound
so he dealt with this 50 over 100 as
half a pound
and as there are 20 shillings in a pound
there will be 10 shillings in half of a
pound
so the answer then became
4 pounds and 10 shillings
now let's tackle abraham lincoln's
homework
so he first converted all the units of
time to months
a year is 12 months and a year and a
quarter is 15 months
he then essentially equated proportions
the interest earned per dollar per month
is the same in both cases
so in one case we have three dollars and
fifty cents
divided by hundred dollars
in twelve months
and in the other case that we're trying
to solve
we have an interest of 38 dollars and 50
cents
divided by the sum that we want and
divided by 15 months
so we can rearrange this expression to
solve for x
so this will be
100 times 12 times 38.5
all divided by 3.5 times 15. so abraham
lincoln multiplied the numbers at the
top and the numbers at the bottom
so the numerator
becomes 46 200 and the denominator
is 52.5
he then did the division and got the
correct answer of 880 dollars
did you figure these problems out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon
you can email me presh
mindyourdecisions.com if you have a math
topic or puzzle suggestion and you can
catch me on social media either at mind
your decisions or at presh tallwalker